こんにちは はじめしゃちょーです。
2018年いよいよ
ワールドカップが
迫ってきました
と 言っ て も あの 僕 は 決して
なんか が できる わけ で は ござい ませ ん がぁ
ワールド カップ は 誰 で も 自由 に 熱く 応援 する こと が できる の で 僕 も 僕 なり に
自由に ワールドカップ を 応援 し たい と 思っ て おり ます そこ で 私 はじめ シャツ を なん と を バドワイザー
イレブン に 選ば れ て おり ます
ワールド カッ プっ て いう の は 誰 で も 自由 に 応援 できる って いう の を 皆 さん に 伝える
使命 が ござい ます。
なので 僕 も 僕 なり に ちょっと 頑張っ て 応援 し たい の で 今回 なん と
ガチモン の チアリーダー の 皆 さん に 弟子入りし て
チアリーディング を 学ぼう と 思い ます
いや、いいんです よ。自由 な ん で、あの 僕 も チアリーダー と し て この ちゃんと 応援 する こと も
ワールド カップ だっ たら 自由な ん で。チアリーディング と いう もの を 本気 で 学ん で
全力 で ワールド カップ を 応援 し たい と 思い ます。もう し て いる みたい な 早速
挨拶と 言っ て いき ましょう で は
こんにちは こんにちはー
は）視聴 皆 さん にチアリーディングっ て いう もの を 教わり に 来 まし た。
チア）はい。よろしくお願いします
チア）私たち は プロフェッショナル
チ）チアリーディング 協会 の オール スター プロ チアリーダーズ です。はじめ しゃ ちょー さん の 熱い 気持ち とっ て も よく 伝わり まし た
チ）もっと 熱く！もっと自由 に！…ですよね？
は）はい そう です。
チ） それ で は 今日 1 日 頑張っ て いき ましょう。よろしくお願いします
チ）今日 はじめしゃちょーさんに 覚え て いただく フリ を 今 から
チ）披露 し たい と 思い ます。しっかり 見 て ください ね
は）わかりました。見ます
チ）はい で お 願い し まー す
[掛け声]
は）なるほど、なるほど
は）いやすごかっ た です。
チ）ありがとう ござい まーす。
は） あれを僕 が 踊れるよう に なる ってことで
は）僕で も ダンス超苦手なん です よね。
チ） 大丈夫です。一番 大事 な の は ダンス より も 気持ち です から
は）気持ち
チ）応援 する 気持ち が 一番 大事 です
は）はい
チ）では早速
チ）準備 体操 から といきましょう か。
は）はい よろしく お 願い し ます
チ）柔らかさじゃなくて伸び てる と 感じることが 大事 です
は）なるほど
チ）入っ て いるので、少しだけやりましょう
チ）さあ、ここ まで は 準備 運動 と いう こと で。ここ から は 本気 で もっと 熱く攻めていき たい と おもい ます。
チ）引き続き よろしくお願いします。
はじめ）余裕ですよ。 頑張り ます よ！
チア）では、先に笑顔の練習を
チア）じゃあまず、笑っ て み ましょう。せー の、ドン！
チア）あ、素敵です。
あとは、もうちょっと 口角 を 上げる と
遠く から 見 て も すごい 笑顔に 見える の で
チア）せーのっ、ドン！かわいい
チア）続い て は パフォーマンス の 振り 移し に なり たい と 思い ます。宜しく お 願いし まー す！笑顔 で
チア）この ポーズ が 終わっ たら、ここでアクロ（バット）を
チア）こうして入れる
チア）ていうのを、やっていただこうと思ってません！
はじめ）ああ、びっくりした。終わったと思った今
チア）いき ます よ
チア）ちょっと遅れたのでもう一度
無理だ
俺 に チアリーダー なんてできねーよ
チア）はじめしゃちょーさん、何やってるんですか
チア）こんな 事 で へこたれ ない で ください。ワールドカップ応援 する ん でしょ。一緒 に 最後 まで 頑張り ましょう
はじめ）いや
はじめ）僕 なんて もう 無理 です よ
チア）はじめしゃちょー、がんばって
チア）応援しましょう、絶対できますよ
はじめ）がんばる か！しゃあ、なん か やる気 が 出 て き まし た
はじめ）がんばるぞー！
はじめ）はい！と いう わけ で みな さん、お疲れさまでし た
はじめ）というわけで、ワールド カップ は です ね 誰 で も 自由に 応援 する こと が でき ます。
はじめ）僕は今回、チアリーダー の 応援 を 学ば せ て いただい た の で
はじめ）ワールド カップ は チア リーダー ぽく 応援 し て みよう か な と 思っ て おり ます
はじめ）僕 みたい に サッカー の こと は あまり 詳しく ない 人 で も、熱く 自由 に 応援 できる の で 皆 さん も ぜひ 応援
し て ください
はじめ）みんな で 盛り上げ て いき ましょう！
はじめ）お疲れさまです
はじめ）美味です
はじめ）はい。と いう わけ で、ツアー リーダー の練習特訓させ て いただき まし た。やっ て み て 思っ た ん です けど
はじめ）本当 に、何 か 全身 の 筋力 を 使う と いう か、運動 量 だけ じゃ なく て 笑顔もずっと絶やすことなく
はじめ）維持し なきゃ いけ ない の で 難しかっ た です。はい、というわけで、バドワイザー な ん です けど もう
はじめ）こちら が なんと、ワールドカップ
限定 の缶 に なっ て おり ます。 通常版がこれ な ん です けど全然色 が 違う し ワールドカップ
イラストが入っていてかっこいいです。
限定 版 の缶に シール が つい て いま こちら に あっ
で この 限定 缶 を 飲ん で こちら の シール で ポイント を 集める と 僕 が 今 着 て いる こちら の
ジャンパー とユニフォームがもらえます。応募 し て み て ください 。見 た 試合 の 中 で 一番
熱かっ た 熱い と 思っ た 選手 を 選ぶ
Man of the Matchと いう もの も 行っ て おり ます。 みな さん ぜひ 参加 し て み て ください
はい、というわけで こちら の url に いろんな 情報 を 全て あり ます の で ぜひ 皆 さんこちらから アクセス し て
画像 を 見 て ください
他 の バドワイザー イレブン の 動画 もこちら に なり ます の で そちらもよかったら是非 見 て ください
はい みな さん ワールド カップ の応援にルールは ない ん です よ
僕みたいなね サッカー の ことが あんまり 知ら ない 人 で も こんな に 楽しく 応援 でき て
バドワイザーもおいしいし
楽しい です よ！というわけで皆 さん もバドワイザー飲み ながら 応援 も 楽しん で ワールドカップ も楽しんで
ハッピー になりましょう！
乾杯
美味也